and finally new role it's time to admit
president Trump has actually
accomplished one good thing he's ruined
the phrase thoughts and prayers forever
of course the problem with thoughts and
prayers has always been that thoughts
are the opposite of prayers one is from
one is from the Enlightenment and one is
from the Exorcist
but it wasn't until Trump tweeted his
thoughts and prayers after the Parkland
shooting and one of the survivors
tweeted back I don't want your
condolences you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
prayers won't fix this that prayer
officially became an eye roll yes
America is finally getting it prayer
doesn't work because if it did every
drug test would come back clean and
there'd be and there'd be no need for
the morning-after pill
but it's more than just prayer thanks to
Trump piety itself has ceased to be a
third rail in American politics how
could it anymore when the world's least
godly man has been so fully embraced by
our most religious people they've
Angelico's oh they love them some Donald
Trump a man who's been to church four
times in his whole life three of them to
get married
the only time he touches a Bible is for
depositions and if he ever went to
confession they'd have to take a meal
break he's into golden showers not the
Golden Rule
[Applause]
it's it's true he does not tweet people
the way he wants to be tweeted so when
Trump got his Mulligan from the Values
Voters that's when we knew religion had
jumped the shark and it was finally safe
to say none for me thanks I had [ __ ]
for lunch look at some of these recent
examples Billy Graham my entire life
I've watched presidents from both
parties suck up to this blowhard like he
was the American Gandhi but when he died
last month it got covered like Olympic
curling local storyteller dead at 99
amorosa last week openly mocked Mike
Pence for believing Jesus tells him to
say things mocked by Omarosa it's like
getting dunked on by Kevin Hart
even Oprah was widely made fun of when
she said God if you think I'm supposed
to run for president you got to tell me
and it has to be so clear that not even
I can miss it and a lot of America said
oh please not the I have to check with
my imaginary friend excuse which was bad
enough when people like Scott Walker
said I am certain this is God's plan for
me something God also told Rick Perry
Rick Santorum ben Carson Michelle
Bachman Herman Cain Sarah Palin God is a
nice guy but he doesn't follow politics
but folks this is progress I used to be
a lonely pioneer here calling religious
thinking a neurological disorder but now
it's like Anil everyone's doing it and
in that there is a lesson for the
Democrats things that used to be third
rails don't have to be third rails
forever Republicans get that for 50
years their fundamental principles were
law enforcement good Russia bad and then
it was Freaky Friday 20 years ago the
idea of arming teachers was universally
derided but now while we point in laughs
they're doing it Democrats on the other
hand begin every gun conversation with I
support the Second Amendment because
they fear this is one of those third
rails that can never be touched even
shooting victims I mean if they wake up
from their coma their first words are I
still support the Second Amendment now
would it be a hard slog to change the
public's mind on guns of course but a
hard slog never phases conservatives
Ronald Reagan used to be a joke now he's
an airport
the Second Amendment is just words
humans made up at a certain moment in
history when they felt right it's an
amendment not a commandment and we could
make up and we could make up new words
again instead of the right of the people
to keep and bear Arms shall not be
infringed we could change it to the
right of the people to apply for the
privilege of possessing non military
style weaponry as long as they're not
batshit crazy shall not be infringed
[Applause]